ja
herzlich willkommen nach jahren mal
wieder zu luca spielt akinator so
freunde wie wir es auch früher in meiner
akinator videos immer gemacht haben
starten wir auch heute wieder mit mehr
als erster personen die wir denken also
seine figur weiblichen nein
[Musik]
der nämlich jetzt schon der redner
ja das war es dann doch vom heutigen
video
existiert eine figur wirklich
wohl schon sagen wurde die figur durch
youtube berühmt ja das stimmt später die
figur minecraft
a
wird er sagen nein hatte eine figur
etwas mit fortnight zu tun würde ich
auch sagen nein das ist eine figur ein
gamer ich würde sagen wahrscheinlich
schwierig hatte eine figur ein musik
video auf youtube daher auf gar keinen
fall habe ich musik video auf youtube
hat deine figur bei eine million
abonnenten ja das stimmt worunter eine
figur in deutschland ja das stimmt auch
hat er lief über blondes haar
sprachen lernen da die ja ich habe auch
blonde haare heißt
sie sind das gar nicht eingeblendet
so
heißt der kanal deiner figur congo after
ja das
er hat mich doch schon erraten mag deine
figur körperkontakt
wir müssen jetzt davon ausgehen dass ich
nicht diese person bin ich einfach sagen
ich weiß nicht
ist die figur gerne leberkäse semmel
bruder plötzlich komplett verarscht ich
würde eher sagen wahrscheinlich nicht
wie man wer isst gerne leberkässemmeln
hat seine figuren spiderman mitgespielt
nein ich mag auch keine komplexen zahlen
und die personen besitzt eine figur ein
besonderes kuscheltier
ich sag ja ach ja keine ahnung und ein
bisschen zu verwirren lebte deine figur
im zeitalter der ritter und burgen ein
bro wir gehörten youtube kanal hat deine
figuren spiderman mitgespielt wird es
mir die frage noch zehnmal stellen nein
habe ich nicht ich hab
frage nochmal kann deine figur sehr gut
schwimmen wahrscheinlich
ich habe sehr fährt hin abzeichen hielt
eine figur minecraft wie ich weiß nicht
was sie isst oder ist dass diese pocket
edition ich habe keine ahnung genau ich
würde eher sagen nein markt eine figur
die geologie
keine ahnung gewann deine figur schon
einmal den triple crown user ja den habe
ich 1804 und spielt die figur movistar
planet ja habe ich zumindest auf einem
kanal gespielt mag deine figur kuba am
boden
bro was ist ein koma
sag einfach ich weiß nicht
stabiles foto übrigens auch von mir
könnt ihr bitte ein anderes von mir
einreichen
ja es ist luca kong crafter ich wurde
über eine million mal gespielt das kam
halt wegen der krassen zeit damals
zuletzt wurde er gespielt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
besseres bild einreichen
[Musik]
jetzt macht
das schicke ich den jetzt bei mail so
das foto habe ich hochgeladen nick name
lukas
wie kommen wir müssen
die was undercover mäßiges nehmen
entdeckt das niemand
hätte der in das foto von mir kommen
sollen wer ist auch egal motivation das
aktuelle fotos falsch ehrwürdigen oder
schockieren ja entwürdigend definitiv
abschicken
ja leute dann müssen wir das jetzt für
mich eintragen
wir nehmen wir dann als nächstes könnte
man sandra probieren ist eine figur
weiblich
ist eine figur ein mensch
oh
ja sagen weil sie nicht kommt eine figur
in einer kinderserie vorher ganz der
kanal als eigentlich kinderserien stammt
eine figur aus einem spiel im app store
das auf gar keinen fall existiert eine
figur wirklich
bestimmt schon hat den figuren handy
leider ja ich wünsche allerdings es wird
ja öfter weggenommen werden also ja sie
hat ein handy kennst du deine figur
persönlich ich sag jetzt einfach mal
nein
weil das macht ja jetzt nicht jemand der
sie wahrscheinlich kennt so ist eine
figur durch tecdoc bekannt geworden ich
sag mal ich weiß nicht keine figur
deutsche hat eine eigene lieder
herausgebrachten nein sie will aber in
diesem jahr noch einen disstrack gegen
mich raus bringen ist die figur durch
youtube berühmt geworden das stimmt ist
ist die katze ist eine figur ein gamer
ist seine figur mit jemandem zusammen
alter anleihen auf gar keinen fall wohnt
eine figur noch bei den eltern
also aktuell jahr
sie ist zwar ausgezogen aber ich sage
trotzdem ja hat denn ich liebe meine
schwester ja sie hat sehr viele
geschwister also ja hat deine figur ein
familienmitglied das berühmte erst als
sie nie
deine figur eindicken
no
way ja sie hat einen dicken bauch oder
dicke hatte es elf nein das komplette
gegenteil ist eine figur hat dann
[Musik]
ist das krank
ist das krank eine etwas korpulentere
weibliche person die etwas mit mir zu
tun hat dass also der kinder muss es
jetzt erkennen deswegen klicke ich jetzt
auf ja und wird
eine figur schuhe sitz mich verarschen
de gaia sandra trägt schuhe hatte eine
figur hat das mit luca zu tun ja das hat
mir gerade schon auch
vor allem das foto
das wollte mit ihren scheiß
fischerhütten da es ist sandra ich bin
mal gespannt wie oft sie auch schon
15.000 mal gut ich gebe euch eine
aufgabe fürs nächste akinator video und
zwar müsst ihr diese schnecke einreichen
wir brauchen auch namen für die
brauchen wir
[Musik]
einen alten bekannten nein meine figur
ist nicht weil ich meine figur wohnt in
deutschland die wurde durch youtube
berühmte sie spielt kein minecraft das
nicht an sie hat auch nichts mit fordern
zu tun sie ist auch kein gamer und sie
hat auch keine musik
keine musik video auf youtube aber es
ist halt ein musikinstrument also keine
ahnung ob er das vielleicht meinte hatte
eine figur ein handy nein diese gitarre
[Applaus]
ukulele hat auch kein handy gehört er
damit meint er mich
ich war es ja diese figur gehört kommt
öfter sie ist aus holz ja oh mein gott
seger was
das foto eingereicht von goldlauter das
habe ich einfach damals eingereicht
worden war ja herr das geht einfach
schneller als sandra und ich diese
verdammte ukulele hier zu erraten also
ja es ist kollegen oft gespielt auch
über eine halbe million war zuletzt vor
gut zuletzt vor 14 minuten bis ein
bisschen kleiner geworden denn genau
an der stelle wo sich das heutige video
zu beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
euch hier endlich mal wieder akinator
mit mir luca gefallen hat das kann einen
daumen runter video dabei
[Musik]